et puis vous le savez la Russie poursuit
l'instrumentalisation de
l'approvisionnement énergétique de
l'Union puisqu'elle réduit
continuellement ses livraisons de gaz
en fait je crois qu'on essaie depuis un
moment elle n'est plus un partenaire et
un fournisseur fiable
et nous le savons aussi c'est les
relations énergétiques maintenant vont
être pour toujours bouleversées par ces
agissements du Kremlin au cours des
derniers mois donc nous allons soutenir
sans ambiguïté aucune les initiatives et
les propositions de la Commission pour
nous préparer non seulement au mieux à
l'hiver prochain mais également au-delà
et donc ça veut dire que la France
effectivement va continuer à soutenir
une réforme structurelle des marchés de
l'énergie pour parvenir à un marché plus
cohérent et moins volatile la commission
c'est engagée à soumettre des
propositions d'ici à la fin de l'année
et comme je sais que ces questions
étaient au coeur de vos réunions du
mercredi 27 juillet avant la suspension
parlementaire aussi des derniers mois et
que vous venez à nouveau de l'émotionner
vous pouvez compter sur nous pour en
rediscuter et vous et vous rendre compte
des avancées
[Musique]